pour l'instant c'est le calme plat à
contrecoeur
cette petite ville de la rive sud
s'apprête pourtant à connaître un grand
bouleversement
l'expansion du port de montréal c'est
pas trop tôt je dirais aux lieux a été
directeur général de la ville de
contrecoeur de 1988 à 2015
j'espérais le voir pendant ma carrière
active mais ce n'est pas arrivé depuis
mai mais je compte à pour les jeunes du
milieu qui a rendu des bêtes des belles
opportunités d'emplois puis je pense que
contre 15 voix ou est reconnu à travers
le monde après ça ça va être intéressant
et pour cela il envisage d'ouvrir pour
ainsi dire une succursale à contre-coeur
sur la rive-sud contrecoeur a été choisi
dans les années 80 pour accueillir les
conteneurs du port de montréal
le jour où il manque la place fil des
ans 4 168 hectares de terrains ont été
acquis soit presque dix fois la
superficie du parc olympique de montréal
les terrains loués à des cultivateurs en
attendant plus récemment l'implication
de la banque de l'infrastructure du
canada a donné de l'élan au projet
pourrait coûter près d'un milliard de
dollars la banque a promis d'investir
jusqu'à 300 millions
[Applaudissements]
cet engagement permet aujourd'hui au
port de montréal de lancer l'appel de
qualification
c'est donc dire qu'un nombre restreint
d'entreprises seront sélectionnés d'ici
la fin de l'année pour répondre à
l'appel d'offres de construction et
qu'on a les permis d'environnement on
pourrait avoir des travaux préparatoires
qui va effectuer par la forme et les
grands du travail savent attendre 2021
donc ça va débuter en 2021
c'est un période de construction d'à peu
près 30 6 mois donc on parle de
livraisons du terminal ici 2020 4 le
port de montréal possède déjà dix neuf
terminaux d'autant à contrecoeur
depuis les années 50 on y des charges du
vrac solide pour alimenter entre autres
l'industrie sidérurgique
le terminal à conteneurs qui s'ajoutera
sera construit un kilomètre en amont à
la limite de verchères une expansion qui
ne plaît pas à tout le monde
propriétaire d'une entreprise
d'excursion nautique stefan droit
plantes s'inquiètent notamment l'impact
des travaux de construction sur la
réserve nationale des îles de
contrecoeur situées en aval du saint
laurent là généralement aux autres il
récupère 90 % du matériel qu'ils
veuillent dernier ils vont peut-être
échapper 5 10 % de matières en
suspension aux méthodes 7 celui-là qui
va descendre vocal mathilde il savoure
amorcé dans les la végétation
environnante et puis ça va deux salles
de secours que roy préparait que le port
de montréal renonce à son projet
d'expansion
les enjeux économiques toutefois sont
énormes l'administration portuaire
estime que 5000 emplois seront créés
lors de la construction du futur
terminal et que 1000 emplois seront
maintenus par la suite
c'est un vecteur économique qui va créer
énormément d'emplois qui vont créer de
la richesse aussi au niveau de la
communauté
contrecoeur attend son nouveau terminal
depuis des années pour plusieurs il est
temps de passer de la parole aux actes
fait longtemps qu'on l'attend fait
longtemps qu'on en entend parler il se
fait longtemps que la planification est
faite dans ce sens là pour nous de port
de montréal c'est resté qu'une date
d'arrivée mais là ça semble de plus en
plus vrai pour 2024
l'administration portuaire devra encore
obtenir différentes autorisations
gouvernementales avant de lancer l'appel
d'offres mais elle semble convaincue de
les obtenir
plus que jamais l'avenir du port de
montréal semble se dessiner un con tre k